[Music]
long before I think before you did Parks
and Rec we met we knew each other and I
we used you on the show in the late
night show as a guy sitting in the
audience because you had the best you
have the best menacing look that's right
if anyone I know get in on that kisser
right there look at that
[Applause]
then you became the Pillsbury Doughboy
now is this right you I can't believe
this because you're such a sweet gentle
guy you used to be a bouncer in Chicago
I did work for a time you know we've all
done sort of every job Michael Douglas
yes
and so yeah I spent some time as a
bouncer at a sports bar I believe called
Halstead Xin Chicago and I was kind of
small for a bouncer but because of my
intimidating glare
I was pretty effective so you're saying
that you never had to actually
physically get involved with anybody or
fight them you could just use your look
yeah as long as I could get them to make
eye contact with me I would I would say
excuse me would you like to talk to me
outside for a moment
and they would often wet themselves and
I just wet myself right now
just watching you custodial staff did
not care for me yeah now you are you
were married to the lovely and talented
Megan Mullally and I'm just curious does
she like this new look you have cuz
you've grown a very manly full beard
well thank you I've grown it because
we're doing a play together here in Los
Angeles I saw which is fantastic
thank you that's generous she she's
something else in it she is my teacher
and so I have the best seat in the house
watching her tear it up every night but
fortunately she is so generous I have
the craziest stupidest looks I shaved my
head I've done I've done mr. T's hairdo
a couple times yeah which I would not
brought four different roles you'll do
what you got to do yeah and she there
was one time that I shaved off the top
of my head but I had a huge hair and
beard and that looked so insane she
wouldn't let me in our bed for a couple
nights which was a hardship and then I
put on a stocking cap
and that just made it okay suddenly yeah
and that you couldn't see how crazy I
looked and back in the sack you are
writing a book you've writing a book on
tips on how to live and I I like you I I
would be interested in a tip could you
give us a tip right now on how to live
that you think would benefit sure yeah
it's uh it's called paddle your own
canoe it's coming out this fall from
Dutton books and there's a lot there's a
lot of tips one one that I give people
often is if you're in a relationship you
should make gestures to your significant
other I always try to make Megan a card
or a gift for anniversaries you make it
yourself yeah like a homemade card well
yeah cards are not that hard I might
like my friends and co-workers often say
to me you know thanks a lot Nick you're
making us look so bad in front of our
wives oh because you made a card yeah
and I say let me tell you something
Rob Lowe you don't have to make [ __ ]
yeah
for everybody else go to the printer
there's paper inside the printer is this
the first tip discern how to get the
paper out of the printer take one sheet
fold it in half draw hard on it sign
your name right I love you the bonus tip
is go outside and get a little piece of
nature a shell or leaf or a chrysalis if
you're good some bark some bark yeah you
got it yeah
your happily married it here that piece
of nature to the center of the heart and
then gets stretched out because you're
going for a ride to the realm of coitus
[Applause]
and an ass at the same time